vi parlerò di scienza di creatività
della mia storia io sono nata a catania
29 anni fa l'ho lasciata 18 anni perché
avevo un sogno volevo fare la differenza
per un mondo migliore
era un po confusa sto sere vv.f volevo
lavorare alle nazioni unite e ho
iniziato a studiare a viaggiare ho
vissuto un anno in egitto ho dedicato
alle mie tesi al mediterraneo sia ai
flussi migratori sia alle opportunità
che la sostenibilità culturale e la
diffusione delle idee avrebbero potuto
dare al
arricchire alle nostre vite nelle nostre
vite e sapevo alla fine del mio percorso
di studi sentivo che le opportunità che
avrei voluto cogliere nella mia vita del
mio futuro sarebbero venute dal
mediterraneo
non sapevo che nella mia vita sarebbe
entrata adriana adriana il catanese ha
37 anni e circa sei anni fa ha deciso di
venire a vivere a milano per inseguire
il suo di sogno fare la moda imparare a
fare la moda e impararlo a milano nel
migliore dei modi con un percorso
d'eccellenza
entrata in casa siamo diventate amiche è
la nostra storia insieme è nata in modo
semplice finché un altra protagonista
non si è inserita questa protagonista è
il frutto un frutto del mediterraneo e
divertente perché ieri sera a cena con
gli altri speaker abbiamo detto ma voi
arance cosa vi fa pensare
l'italiano la sicilia no in realtà c è
stato chi ha detto tunisia che ha detto
egitto perché è un frutto del
mediterraneo dunque un'arancia io ed
adriana cosa c'entriamo delle persone
così diverse è un frutto semplice
adriana stava scrivendo la sua tesi sui
tessuti innovativi e sostenibili e si è
imbattuta in questa foto che rappresenta
un agrumeto siciliano in cui l'arancio e
non vengono raccolte quindi un amico
agronomo che lamentava questo problema
in sicilia è fatta una domanda come come
questa potesse diventare per lei
cilea per la terra che profondamente
amava da cui è partita ma dove voleva
tornare potesse rappresentare
le voleva creare un prodotto unico e
innovativo per la moda quindi e voleva
farlo dalle arance quindi ha preso un
arancia la spremuta ha preso le bucce le
ha messe sul termosifone li ha fatti
essiccare e ha convinto una
professoressa di chimica dei materiali
del politecnico di milano a entrare nel
suo laboratorio
io avevo paura a farla stare in cucina
è il polito della giocare con le
provette in un dipartimento di chimica
lì è successo che è riuscito a provare
la fattibilità della sua idea cioè si
poteva fare un filato a partire dagli
agrumi ma non avevamo un filato in quel
momento qualcosa nella sua mente nella
mia vita è cambiato lei ha deciso di
diventare imprenditrice quindi non di
depositare un brevetto e venderlo o
trovare qualcuno che lo realizzasse ma
di aggregare intorno a quest'idea le
persone le risorse perché il suo sogno
diventasse realtà e in questo viaggio mi
accor mia mi ha coinvolta mi ha chiesto
ti andrebbe di raccontare con me questa
storia bisogna essere almeno in due
perché sia credibile è così io ho smesso
di fare quello che stavo facendo e ho
provato a raccontare questa storia in
cui ho iniziato a credere tanto che
quest'anno la nostra azienda ha chiuso
il suo primo anno di attività abbiamo
raccolto dei fondi e abbiamo siamo state
estremamente emozionati e felici quando
da questo che lo scarto di agrumi siamo
riusciti ad ottenere questo che della
cellulosa e da cui siamo riusciti a fare
questo il primo affilato al mondo dagli
agrumi si può fare
a quel punto ci sia posto un altro
problema vogliamo fare il filato cosa
vogliamo fare
abbiamo deciso di fare un tessuto che
fosse per la moda quindi un tessuto che
somigliasse alla seta che potesse essere
utilizzato dai brand di moda e che fosse
utile anche per il consumatore quindi
per chiunque lo indossa rilasciato dei
principi attivi benefici e naturali che
dessero ancora più soddisfazione
ora c'è solo un problema voi vi
chiederete
noi ogni giorno cosa facciamo
cioè dove le prendiamo le arance siamo
siamo lì ci vendiamo in ufficio no
quello che abbiamo scoperto in
quest'anno da da imprenditrici in
quest'anno alla ricerca delle eccellenze
italiane alla ricerca di fondi abbiamo
scoperto che l'industria della
spremitura delle arance genera ogni anno
solo in italia 700 mila tonnellate di
sottoprodotto
questo va smaltito ci sono dei metodi
legali ci sono nei metodi illegali di
base c'è un problema noi recuperiamo
questo scatto siamo state siamo
accettate in un impianto di
trasformazione industriale dove stiamo
modificando una linea di produzione per
non movimentare questo scatto estrarre
da lì la nostra materia prima
quindi noi vogliamo il messaggio che
vogliamo portare non è solo un messaggio
di innovazione e di imprenditoria ma
anche un messaggio di sostenibilità e la
moda che influenza il nostro modo di
fare il mostro il nostro modo di essere
di mostrarci agli altri può essere deve
essere il veicolo di questo messaggio e
di come la sostenibilità deve entrare a
far parte delle nostre vite quindi per
noi la la creatività è stato un modo di
coniugare stile innovazione funzionalità
e rispetto per l'ambiente
vi visto che sono qui a parlarvi anche
di
tradizione e innovazione
vi vorrei salutare con questa foto
questa è la foto di un giardino pantesco
cioè questo è la foto scattata a
pantelleria è quello che vedete ritratto
è una costruzione in pietra lavica che
circonda un albero centenario d'agrumi
quello che vedete la costruzione risale
a circa tremila anni fa perché le
condizioni climatiche di quelli se non
l'ho fatto sì che gli abitanti per avere
quei frutti e per far sì che la pianta
non so commesse all'aridità alla siccità
hanno inventato questa fortificazione
all anno importata perché pare essere un
modello di origine araba per proteggere
gli agrumi
l'arancio l'albero d'arancio che c'è lì
dentro e secolare ed è della tipologia
portogallo perché le arance la sorella
lancia un po controversa c'è chi vi dice
che viene dall'asia c'è chi dice che il
nome sia di origine per sarà sicuramente
un frutto del mediterraneo ecco questo
secondo me simboleggia come l'intelletto
si è dovuto degli esseri umani si è
dovuto fino a oggi adattare al alla
natura per soddisfare i propri bisogni e
come noi oggi invece ci troviamo di
fronte ad un'altra sfida quella di
utilizzare il nostro intelletto e la
creatività per creare dei bisogni che
proteggano l'ambiente che salvino la
nostra natura e questo è quello che noi
abbiamo fatto a partire dal dallo stesso
frutto ed al cuore del mediterraneo